thank you
[Music]
so I talked about this a little bit
earlier but it has nothing to do with
all of you hi
um we're talking about John F Kennedy
Robert F Kennedy Jr
who is running for president of the
United States
will the Democrats let him challenge Joe
Biden's go Anthony go well the Democrats
already said that they're not going to
allow uh primaries
primary debates they said they're not
going to do it no debates no debates
because there's already a seating
presidents so why okay go ahead now you
could talk I already threw away the key
okay
he was pulling at 19 percent
he is no his campaign has support so
that and that and he just got started
right he just announced within a month
yep yep he does um he's very articulate
but his voice is very uh whack very
interesting he had a surgery I think on
his throat he's gonna lose it he's gonna
know what it is
sounds like Val Kilmer if humans don't
like his voice they're not gonna win no
matter if they're saying the good [__]
yeah you think it's not more like Obama
I think so I think
people don't realize how stupid most
Americans are Oh They'll choose a
president based on Lovely people when
they do this yeah
yeah they choose them on like oh this
guy looks taller he's cooler looking
we're going to choose to be honest when
I'm voting and then it comes down to the
other people not the president I just
vote for sometimes a person that I heard
of more that happens which sucks but
like the people that that they get their
name recognized the most that's why they
campaign like with the mark banners it's
the signs everywhere I'm like that's how
that sign hell a lot yeah and I hate
that it must be a good one yeah yeah I
don't even fill those in if I don't know
anything about them
so RFK Jr suffers from spasmodic
dysphoria which causes his voice to
quiver and makes speech difficult I
think he still gets through it pretty
well he gets yeah it gets to it it's
still very easy to hear what he's saying
yeah it's just like oh [__] there's
something you sound like do an
impersonation
yeah go ahead yeah do it
and seven years ago oh wow
radio voice calls and seven years ago
you know what I miss is I remember uh
wasn't there like a standard not
transatlantic but there was like a
standard political speech and a radio
speech I want people to speak like that
again that are official oh yeah that's
like back in the day but it's because of
the way that the radio picked up their
voice right it like pitched them in a
certain way yeah like the Hindenburg uh
broadcast yeah yeah
I will say though that uh when you
compare even speech though with RFK at
least you can still understand what he's
saying whereas Joe Biden he speaks kind
of regular but you still oh dude it's so
true well you're talking about a present
like that dude
where's your hats his president no I
threw it all the way oh yeah why don't
you make it awkward dude we're supposed
to be hive mind here we're the woke Team
bro we're the wolf hey dude walkways did
um so Biden launched a lot of his
previous support right based on his his
popularity is pretty low it seems like
it how how low is it his negative rating
is above his positive rating well that's
pretty bad
but every seating metric every seating
president toward the end it's all it's
always like that I don't know one
president in my lifetime even Obama
Obama was like that
really yeah he was popular the whole
time okay everyone loved Obama I mean
because he was cool his disapproved
Biden is 52.3 his approve is 42.7 I've
never seen a video of uh Joe Biden going
paddle boarding but I've seen Obama go
paddle boarding and that makes me feel
like he's an everyday man he's the guy
he's the guy being a bro being do you
think Joe Ben would know he's
paddleboarding yes
he'd be on his knees the whole time they
wouldn't let him he can't he can't go up
the stairs no yeah that's true he goes
up the stairs technically but he's
stumbling up the stairs see that video
is do you remember that video which one
there's like two of them now the one
where he trips and then tries to speed
up to like you know because I've done
that I've tripped and then
try to make it look like A din trip and
I tripped again so that's kind of a one
of us thing right yeah that's a one of
them if there's a city president though
why would they want to uh challenge that
from the same camp like that's never
happened before right like them over
them yeah it's never no one's ever
successfully uh primary day usually a
sitting president has a high chance of
continuing their reign for the next term
devil is old as [__] so RFK he doesn't
have a shot at uh being the main guy I
don't think it's likely because they're
not gonna let him debate so that means
he's not going to get a platform on the
national stage against Biden yeah then
on the Republican side Trump's not going
to debate like there's already talk
about him not debating DeSantis even
when DeSantis announces really because
he's pulling so much higher than the guy
so why would he like invite him on the
stage but then again it's Trump you
never know what the guy
I thought they were supposed to have a
primary run though like they are because
the Republican the challenging side is
supposed to have a primary debate and
run right
yeah but I mean Trump could just I mean
he doesn't need that he doesn't need it
and a couple things happened the last
time too like Trump didn't do the second
debate remember that there was three
debates scheduled and he canceled in the
second one like we already got it in the
bag what's the point well no he had he
had covered if you remember but then um
it was also found out like around that
time we even covered at the time that
the guy who was interviewing him used to
like be a a Joe Biden intern like back
in the day oh I was like that's [__]
weird right
um so but they're they're basically
saying I mean if you remember what
happened with um Hillary Clinton against
Bernie the way that they they structured
the super delegates and the way that
they they apportioned funding from the
DNC they purposely kicked Bernie out
like suppressed his campaign as much as
they could they actually admitted to
doing that later on the woman named
Donna Brazil she was the head of the DNC
during that and came out in her book and
said that they did that so there's
people saying why would they let Kennedy
run like why would they let Kennedy yeah
if he's anti-establishment yeah anti-war
anti-establishment anti-big Pharma right
that's interesting but maybe that's
low-key trending in this time frame it
seems like there's an undercurrent yeah
but also wouldn't that just split the
vote for the Democratic like 100 your
highest chance to win is to keep your
president yeah keep your yeah keep the
seat keep it status quo well you said
something uh dope earlier in the other
video where um sometimes not so much
about like Republican and Democrats
sometimes more like establishment
anti-establishment yeah you know what I
mean so just kind of trying to read
between the lines and figure out what's
going to be the best representative I
think for the people we would all like
it to be disrupted and changed because
the old guard's been in power too long
exploiting us right but then
I'm thinking like if you were a Old
Guard Democrat
and if you wanted to stay in power you
didn't want the Republicans you know to
have that seat then it's like it just
makes more sense to leave Biden up there
even if you got to pretend that he's not
got dementia and you can speak coherent
sentences what would you guys say is
let's go around the room the number one
topic like our number one issue that you
want fixed right now that you would vote
for oh man oh man uh little boys being
able to go into little girls bathrooms
yeah me too that's the number one most
important thing for me like there's
nothing else because we're such a good
country and there's nothing else to talk
about yeah that's the only thing
um make it up
easier is not the right word but um
having a better gun roster for
California a what a better gun roster
for California what does that mean
meaning like the gun roster that we
currently have is pretty [__] and also
the laws in place for California are
more in favor of the criminals it's very
difficult okay got it like you want to
put more guns on the ban list I want a
gatliner
yeah yeah I want uh criminals to have
you know more freedom it does especially
for vehicular care more about the
criminals than the victims oh yeah it's
it's really difficult to even like
protect yourself at this point yeah yeah
um you know and even at this point it's
a it's like a catch and release
situation so yeah that that's a big but
would you say that's a federal state
specific well maybe if uh yeah that's
true it's probably specific because some
states
but I asked I asked well yeah that's a
fair answer yeah because the question I
asked is like what's the number one
issue but it would it would be nice if
there was some kind of thing that
prevented States from being allowed to
be soft on crime
but whatever
interesting
I think the growing I mean this it's
very very difficult to like wrap this
into a single thing but like the growing
wealth divide
um I mean what personally affects us is
most of us are like you know I guess we
would uh be classified as like the
middle class which is the one that pays
the most and like receives the least you
know what I mean yeah so with with this
growing like higher oligarchy of of
American Wealth you know what I mean in
legislation and all that stuff in favor
of like the the one percent and then
this growing you know uh
poor economy out here that's like people
are getting kind of [__] it it's just
going to create more division it's going
to create much more crime it's going to
create a lot of a lot of those things so
when things like an RFK talks about like
you know going against big Pharma or
even like being like anti-war you know
what I mean like I don't want to blanket
and be like yo I'd rather this be
anti-war but it is a weird thing to try
and
you know put your money somewhere else
outside of the country when there's like
a lot of financial problems inside the
country too you know yeah my number one
thing would be I don't know how on Earth
this could be possible but in some way
to limit the damage that can come from
media
um
that would be incredible and I have no
clue yeah because like how are you gonna
like filter through no chance for hell
from like from like manipulated media
not like people like obviously just just
when when it's so clear that the script
is uh but it's like who's who's the
judge of that it was in the 90s there
was a law where
um every Media or like news Outlet had
to report 30 of the opposition so there
was interesting it wasn't such an echo
chamber where
um they can all be behind like one thing
it was like
we had a little bit more like moderate
thinking because
they were required to do that and I
think at some point they removed that
law it was like when Clinton got in I
think it was called the fairness doctor
or anything yeah interesting yeah okay
that stuff that is yeah I don't know
what could be about enough I don't know
a solution that at all level I do think
that like so like things like PBS like
education channels for children
something like supported by viewers like
you yeah now we don't watch TV anymore
but we're all online now right yeah so
then kids can grow up just watching
entertaining content and not educational
content but I do think like the way you
heal a country or fix it is to
continuously raise the bar for the
lowest members of society so like if you
can if the poorest people of today
live better than the poorest people of
100 years ago then we're doing a good
job and we just got to keep pushing that
bar but also like in the future We're
not gonna have manufacturing and labor
and like
hat like just straight blue collared
jobs right yeah so that's going to be an
interesting thing in the future because
it's like are we going to have ai are we
gonna have because the world still needs
people to fix the bridges fix the roads
and that's disappearing so like the
infrastructure is getting [__] up you
don't have like blue collared work
programs for youth so like wood shop
working electricians yeah all of that
stuff it's like we rely mostly on like
immigrant labor or a dying American
population that's in it right now so
it's like what's gonna happen in the
future when everyone just knows how to
use computers and no one knows how to
fix a computer
all that stuff yeah we're just
Innovative out of a job yeah it's
actually a really good point and also
like um with you know like the the
without religion that was balancing the
more
um ethical moral and like yeah it was
like a moral compass right like and then
and then so now how do we how do we I
guess I don't know if replacing is the
word but figuring out a uniform thing
that connects Americans together because
we're too damn divided yeah that's
living
too far away where we look at each other
as like you're the enemy Democrats and
Republicans used to 100 fight but not
like you're a different country you're
trying to take over
well they used to pretend to fight they
used to pretend yeah [__] yeah yeah yeah
yeah I think there's also the whole like
thing of somehow getting rid of the
illusion that there's Elite intelligence
in defiance like just because you're
disagreeing doesn't mean that's the
smartest thing to say which I feel like
everybody kind of gravitates to that now
they're just like oh I need to say the
thing no one's saying in the comments in
order to stand out and be like the
smartest thinker it's like kind of
further divides an already divided issue
yeah
for me Healthcare big big time
it's [__] it's insane in America bro
we don't have health care insurance
exactly insurance companies and they're
never reigned in they're never reined in
ever they're making everyone fight with
everybody doctors fight with the
hospital hospitals [__] fight with
patients like no one's getting good care
people with cash are that's right and
you have to have a [__] load of that
also Healthcare is really difficult when
just the overall health in general is
bad yeah that's true we need to I think
I've lost hope we need we need updated
education on nutrition and like the food
pyramid that thing that the FDA came out
with those are they finally like Cocoa
Puffs not be a healthy dude the factory
farms [__] wrote that [__] dude they
funnel people into that mindset yeah
drink but they're so young it's good for
your bones at least now there's like a
step towards that direction of finding
truth in that pyramid yeah but I mean I
think that the problem with America
though is everything's for sale so our
politicians so it's not like other
countries where they're they're
literally like okay these things are off
limits these things are for our people
the longevity of their health there's
actually some type of Ethics behind it
for us it's all for sale that is sacred
we have oligarchies too Everyone likes
to talk about the Russian oligarchies
I'm like dude that is that is the
American system bro it's called Tony
capitalism yeah that's but then there is
a backfire to that whole thing when like
let's say you you've heard all your all
your life to drink milk or eat potatoes
like crazy but your state makes the most
potatoes so you your state is Rich
because they're exporting and they have
this whole thing in this whole marketing
behind it and the more you push back on
that the less Revenue you actually are
gonna make for your environment and that
is kind of a pushback or a backfire like
if you're if you're if you're a candy
state exactly yeah like if you make cane
sugar right or something and then now
it's like everyone's not eating sugar
guess what your state now is less money
so it's like kind of like uh people are
gonna there is a catch-22 fix the entire
economy first like like they say uh the
pharmaceutical industry the healthcare
industry but then if you wipe it out all
at once what are people gonna do to
replace that income right yeah like we
can't have a usurping of a revolutionary
kind of thing where you just switch
sides because that never historically
went well for anybody or create a bunch
of government jobs
or
is this supposed to be a long video yeah
oh it's an OTR oh okay
what is your no that's it it's just like
a simple answer to a complicated
question I think as long as you go bit
by bit and then try to reduce corruption
that's that's nice well like you know
what you know what I think Civil War
where would you start is the question I
think okay so this is this is my yeah
the pineapple barometer for Morality is
like is the short-term gain worth the
long-term detriment and if we're talking
about nation building it's like
is having half the population hooked on
Pharmaceuticals good for the future okay
no right because you want so like for
example like like in Japan the first
three years of schooling for children is
just learning how to civilize them they
clean up the classrooms they learn the
rules of the road and they learn
etiquette and and like and then that's
why you have independent kids at like
five six years old running errands going
all this stuff right but also they don't
have the same threats they don't have
kidnapping the way that we do yeah for
sure extravaging and all that in the
same must be nice so whatever right so
but the the the focus of the nation and
some people argue that this is what
happens when you get a homogeneous
Nation because then everyone's looking
at each other as like family and the
same people and you're not exploiting
each other yeah whereas American America
it's like maybe the ones in power are
like they're not one of us there's no
default cultural value so the the level
of how much they can exploit each other
is like well they're not uh our tribe so
it doesn't right right but the longevity
I I feel like when you when you invest
in your people that way the long-term
benefits behind that outweigh the
short-term gain of whatever you can make
but we're very I think we're very
short-term gang country because it's a
young country compared to a country like
China right where they could plan [__]
for 100 years straight and they're
probably gonna win because they don't
have so much infighting yeah they're not
allowed to deviate from the hundred year
plan exactly where we're just trying to
do
small gains within our lifetimes who the
[__] cares happens to our ancestors
right but when you think in terms of the
way that like China or just that that
old cultures they think long term they
think generationally they go I'm gonna
buy a house and give it to my great
great great grandkids right yeah whereas
like when you're thinking more
independent and just you
individualist cultures you don't think
about how is this going to go down the
line you just think like I'm gonna make
a [__] ton of money I'm a ball out and
then maybe I'll give it to my kids if
they're if they deserve it
so it's a different mentality we also
think we have to make a function because
we do have to make a [__] ton of money
because like right you have no choice
yeah yeah you have no shot you have to
be a freaking star in whatever you do
and if you do make money you're getting
taxed up and out the [__] seriously
and the IRS is such a wild system too
like the amount of notices you get like
like in the most random ways if you're a
business owner yeah you're just like
whoa I have another dude yeah oh my God
yeah anytime I get an envelope from the
IRS my heart's beat now I [__] [__]
and I'm like oh but it's nothing at the
end of the day they're real quick to
take your payment but real slow to it oh
yeah [__] jerks dude
I respect you guys I'm just kidding I
don't
know right it is very like difficult to
get a leg up even if you're doing
everything right that's what I hear the
most from everybody but like as I get
older I totally get why people because
when I was younger I used to be like why
why are you why are the people so evil
man and then as I get older I'm like oh
dude I would if I had the opportunity to
sell out I totally would right and be a
corrupt guy be on CNN getting like 30
000 a day yeah say a bunch of dribble no
problem
that's true [__] it this is my this is
me shooting my shot right yeah because
it almost feels like fighting that is so
hard yeah that's how the world works
well yeah and it is true that like you
can't really say you can't really
condemn others when until you have had
the opportunity it's for real like when
you have all these protesters there like
how dare they yeah but were they in the
same position it's hard to say they
would decline it I mean I feel like
everyone's just trying to feed their
family right right everyone's big enough
that's really their goal or themselves
or themselves
and everyone finds a way to justify
their actions because it's the the
responsibility is split like it's not
just all on you right that's the thing
if everybody was taken care of you would
have more choices to make choices well
some people would argue that people are
taken care of that's the difference
right so that's true too like in America
like the our poorest people are actually
the richest people of the world so if
you compare poverty in America they
still wealthier than the rest of the
world yeah so then so then it's like if
you're looking at a global scale the
people that are empowered they're like
well you should be grateful you still
live better than someone in this third
world country I think we should be
judged by how we take care of the people
with the least in our society and every
time I drive by the 10th cities I'm like
yeah we are not doing [__] for these
people yeah we're [__] where does the
money go I would love to know but it's
not I mean it's hard to do things for
people who don't want to do things for
themselves there's also that true that's
also true I like looking at one level
above that and just the people that are
working five jobs right yeah right right
I'm like we can help them right I see
that a lot bro yeah they're not American
usually we could maybe not tax them as
hard that'd be nice the amount of job
that's like a middle class life in
Hawaii dude so in Hawaii like it's 40
it's rank 42 state for um job
opportunity congrats but it's like top
three of EX like how expensive it is
right so a middle class life out there
is lower middle class on the mainland
you have to make like 80 to 100K to live
and like it sucks because those are the
natives yeah yeah like the natives can't
live in their own yeah right yes right
look at us bro you can have foreign
money come in buy property foreign
governments can buy property in America
yeah price out the locals like everybody
you know you can't buy a house in
America very easily anymore they just
raised interest rates again yeah right
so then you have you're competing not
just with your neighbors and other
people who are working but you're
competing with foreign governments yeah
but that's what I mean is there's no
cash buyers everything is for sale in
America in Bali you can't buy property
if you're a foreigner you're not allowed
same with Singapore yeah yeah and how
come
but we can't have those rules is because
the people that run or own America
they're like let the most like the most
money win yeah most money they don't
care if you're Chinese or Saudi Arabian
or whatever they don't give up and when
people bring this up they go oh well you
just don't want that race to buy
property it's like it's a government
dude it's the [__] it's the oligarchs
yeah it's just so funny how they use
those issues to just like make people
shut up or these corporations that are
expanding their portfolios like buying
every house in your immediate radius
that's insane yeah that's [__] well
blackrock's kind of chill too though
they're American aren't they yeah
foreign